hello academy member
and thank you so much for tuning in to
myself
and dante uh my name is dion taylor i am
the director
of the movie fatale which stars two-time
academy award winner hilary swank
michael ealy mike colter and demaris
lewis
and i am very very excited to have my
brother
mr dante spanatti two-time academy
nominated cinematographer
and um my close friend and dante how are
you today man
i'm great thank you for inviting me to
this
let's talk a little bit about fatale
this was a special movie for us because
dante got to revisit los angeles
and photograph it again after 20 plus
years
dante what did you what's your thoughts
on being back in l.a and shooting
i felt great because l.a to me is uh
possibly the most important
visually most fascinating
location you can think of for a movie it
allows
big vistas it allows very strong
character location everywhere
the whole different people the different
people that lives in this town
so long leave los angeles yeah i would i
would say that
you know it was an honor for me to watch
you shoot in la
um just being a fan of heat and and so
many of
the other films that you've touched and
and lit
um but you know this movie was a little
bit different for both of us
based on the fact that unlike some of
the bigger films this movie was
independent
and we did have a lot of budget
constraints this was a movie where
me and you basically were averaging 70
to 85
sometimes 90 setups a day how is that
for you
you know going back to the world of like
manhunter where
there is no tomorrow like we got to go
right now and you got to get it done
how was that for you yeah you go you go
and you have
at times limited amount of time and what
really helps the situation like that is
uh of course your experience i gotta say
your capacity of bringing enthusiasm
on everybody working on the movie and
the fact that i could refer
come to you and say hey you know dion we
could do this
uh how about doing this we got half an
hour or whatever why don't we do it
this way and knowing that your yes or no
was totally reliable was a key a key
component of this
yeah i mean it's a different world when
you make independent films and it's a
different world when you
you know you know there is no tomorrow
there is no reshoots
one of the most challenging scenes for
me and you on this film
was this beautiful scene on the beach
and
we basically originally had a day and a
half
to shoot a exterior
shot of the beach and an interior shot
of the beach house
and you said dion we have to shoot this
scene
in the natural sunlight and we need to
shoot this scene over the course of
three days
and i remember going okay who's going to
be the one to tell don say we can't do
this
and um after me you talked about it
and i understood what you were saying we
adjusted everything we could in the film
to make this happen
and just so people understand what we're
talking about let's show the clip
which is uh michael eatley discovers
that his wife is cheating on him
and he decides to go into the beach
house where
they are actually cheating
this
i'm so sorry
[Music]
just
[Music]
don't act so surprised
and then you did it
you went back to your car got a gun
[Applause]
you went back to that bedroom
[Music]
and you killed me
so as you think about this scene dante
what was your thinking behind the light
here well you know i think uh
the key element of this that we
discussed was that this is a kind of a
surreal
scene right this is what the
hillary's wank is a detective is trying
to
put into michael keeley's mind
right as a as if it had really happened
so i mean the tricky part of scenes like
this is really to
make a plan you know some of these
things are shot at night
when we don't see the big window in the
bedroom uh
last night we had a big light in the
middle of the beach
exactly from the same direction where
the sun was coming from
there is one shot at the end where we
can see the real sun
you know light in the actors but i had
to
go into the night i couldn't ask you to
just shoot for two hours before sunset
and then wrap and go home
we had to figure out a way to you know
be ready to
have all the equipment ready to go and
put a big light replacing the sun in the
middle of the beach and
keep shooting keeping those magic
moments
for the wide shots i think in the whole
scene there are a couple occasions like
that
and again the fact that the scene was uh
not real
really gave us some opportunities to go
for some really
surreal magic lighting i like the look
of the
window it's sunset with all those clouds
outside and
the three people standing in bed the
fact that at the beginning he
sees them reflected in the mirror but in
that shot we don't see the big window
we don't see outside so we could shoot
that when he was dark
right yeah i would agree man and one of
the things i thought was
absolutely incredible that you were able
to do
is to do this practically i mean that is
really the sun going down
and that is really the lighting in that
room and uh i remember walking the beach
with you for
over an hour trying to decide which
one of those beach houses the sun would
hit the correct way
and when you see it all put together i
think this scene
in the film is arguably one of the most
beautiful scenes i've actually seen
captured on camera especially when you
talk about dealing with
black skinned black people it's just
beautifully done man so bravo to you for
that
the next thing that i think we should
definitely discuss
is a giant action sequence with two-time
academy award winner hilary swank
this scene that we're getting ready to
discuss is
just crazy it's just it's just it's when
the movie turns left and everyone goes
oh my god what's happening
and the scene is basically when the bad
guys
grab hillary swank they're going to take
her to a bathroom because she's actually
acted as if she's sick and she needs a
moment they want information from her
so they drag her to this bathroom so
let's watch the scene really fast on
what happens here
and then let's talk about how hard it
was to put that scene together and what
you were thinking when we shot it
stop playing with me hurry the [ __ ] up
you good yeah i might man hurry up and
bring her ass
up
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
that scene was incredible this is a
scene in the movie where
audiences go crazy they've lost their
minds
is hillary swank shooting full
on camera you don't get any better than
that now
dante as we were putting that scene
together i don't know if you remember
this was a 19-hour day for us it's
hour 19 the fire marshal is kicking
us out of the loft that we're in
they're telling us that we have 30
minutes to get
these last shots that we need which is
hillary
in the bathroom getting a gun coming out
and going down the hallway and shooting
a gun twice to actually you know
get the actor tyrant turner and
we have about maybe 13 setups to do in
30 minutes yeah last
last day of the movie so we can't come
back dante tell me what you were
thinking during this scene man
and and how you were able to put that
together that was a great day
i didn't like it that day but now that i
think about it i go man that was a great
day
well you know the first thing to say
that i would like to say here is that
that is the beauty of making movies like
this which are independent because
now actors inspire you by just looking
at the face and the way hillary moves
that would suggest how you should the
scene how you better
tell the story of this lady i remember
heavily relying on
practical unexisting lights so i think
basically in the bathroom
we see two things it was just a light on
the top of the ceiling
that i remember off or one on top of the
mirror
above the sink something like that yes
this beautiful steadicam shot
that rosenfeld executed she comes in and
out of these top lights
you know she also do well for the energy
of the shop she looks great
powerful energetic how could she do it i
don't know
right i don't i don't know either i just
know that that scene
forever will be instilled in me as one
of the
craziest funnest you know
scariest scenes that i've ever shot
because i knew that we could not get
back into that apartment
i knew we could not get hillary back i
knew that we couldn't get the production
back so
to be able to pull off a scene like that
man took a lot of work and
you know you being able to snap back
into
that independent mindset of
just move the camera and get it done
light it and sometimes what i've learned
is
when you don't think and you just act
you get some of the best work you've
ever seen
uh if you were right sometimes when you
storyboard things and
create all these beautiful lights and
you you know and you have this pretty
picture and on paper
and then you actually get to the
location and you go no it needs to be
like this
and i think that's what's really really
cool about independent filmmaking
and just the beauty of filmmaking all at
once
um so dante before we go
you've made some of the most incredible
films
that we have ever seen um you have
worked with some of the most prolific
filmmakers that we have ever met and
seen
when you look back on your work at times
um do you ever see things that you feel
like you should have done differently
with some of these movies
is there something where you go man i
should have did this even though the
whole world is saying
this is incredible do you sometimes go
that light was wrong you know maybe but
the main thing is the way
my work life came across he's more like
you know i moved from italy then i gave
it a try then i abandoned everything in
italy
came over to carolina and dino de
verentes
and i work with michael maine and other
directors and bruce beresford
and so forth if i look back i said hey
listen i should have been way less
anxious
i should've invited more uh you know
forgetting
i mean the whole operation of getting to
know
new crews new people new situations
um has some really positive
sides which i think that at the end of
this the end i mean i don't know
but right now the way i am right now i
have a chance of
doing some amazing work with you that's
you know it's
and besides being amazing it's also very
pleasant so i think it's more about that
it's much about not not you know
tackling things without
without anxiety without worrying uh you
know
just enjoy go for it and this is
probably
a more critical thing than the aesthetic
factor itself
or technical factor itself you have to
enjoy change you have to look for change
and don't
don't be afraid of obstacles yeah and i
think
what you just said is why me and you uh
have become so close
i truly believe every word you just said
and
one thing i would give as advice to
anyone that might be out here listening
that might
you know catch me and you talking about
film talking about fatale
is be adventurous and never be afraid to
take a chance on yourself um most don't
know that i am a self-taught filmmaker i
never went to film school
i just kind of learned how to make film
because i loved it
and um life is very strange man over the
course of time you just keep putting
your heart into things and putting your
passion into things
and eventually that boat of passion gets
you to meet other people like yourself
and you don't never know where you're
gonna go and uh i've been very blessed
dante to know you
i've been very blessed to be able to
work and make three films with you and i
wanted to tell you thank you for that
man you are
a pioneer uh you're a legend and uh
i am hopeful that everyone takes a
moment
to give you a bow and an applause
because you definitely deserve it man i
love you and thank you for
fatale and uh academy member thank you
so much
for watching us ramble and talk and
laugh
and uh please i hope you have an
opportunity to see fatale
if you've seen it thank you so much for
supporting us and
also for supporting independent film
thank you so much